hallo meine hand herzlich willkommen
meine damen und herren heute zur
mittlerweile schon dritten episode von
lukas mann
ich sitze hier heute meine damen und
herren wir bereits sehen könnt nicht
alleine sondern legen
denn ich habe selbstverständlich wir
sehen wieder meine mobile monday es mit
luca brille aufgezogen habe sondern auch
eine brille gegeben weil ich dachte das
passt einfach zu dieser serie die
unterstützt wird von google play im
rahmen der playon kampagne also
dankeschön google play dass ihr das
heutige video wieder tatkräftig
unterstützt und wir zocken auch
selbstverständlich wieder ein spiel und
zwar heute zusammen
stadt land fluss wir spielen und jeder
drei runden stadt land fluss also
insgesamt sechs runden und in jeder
runde haben wir vermutlich einen anderen
buchstaben aber wir treten nicht
gegeneinander an
mit dem gleichen buchstaben sondern
jeder kriegt zufällig in den buchstaben
dann gucken wir am ende gewonnen hat ich
würde sagen ich folge mit der ersten
runde und zwar seht ihr hier schon meine
kategorien zugelost etwas rote
sportarten sprachen startaufstellung
typisch deutsch möchte gern einmal aufs
spiel starten und jetzt darf ich das rad
drehen und dementsprechend welcher
buchstabe rauskommt ist die brille gar
nichts okay vielleicht spielen wir dann
beide nur mit dieser brücke also ich
drehe nun das rad meine lieben freunde
meinen buchstabe ist der buchstabe o
glaube ich los gehts meine damen und
herren 3 2 1 und jetzt ist es auf zwei
etwas rotes mit
oh mein gott helfen ich weiß ich weiß
sein weiß ruth hacker ja
erst mal weiter mit der nächsten sache
sportart mit
ich kenne ich war nie so gut auf alles
klar ich hab einfach und ich habe keine
ahnung im sprache mit komplett auf dem
schlauch österreichisch deutsch
hauptstädte mit welches land ich habe
keine angst vor laufen schlauer ist kein
aber lehne ich mir vor auf dem schlauch
typisch deutsch was ist denn typisch
deutsch mit
das ist in zwei sekunden eine sekunde
jetzt vorbei das hast du richtig nichts
ich hab nur otto in der kritik
ich hoffe ich habe eineinhalb von fünf
sternen weil österreichisch dazu habe
ich einen halben punkt für bekommen also
du trägst du jetzt jetzt rat und kriegst
einen buchstaben und dann gucken wir
oktober mehr als ein 1 1 hinaus
genau hey luca aus dem schnitt hier erst
mal sorry für beide kaputte stimmung für
mein aussehen hier allerdings bin ich
komplett erkältet das habe ich
allerdings nicht davon abhalten und hier
diesen kurzen video einspieler hier für
euch zu drehen und zwar wollte ich euch
das ganze spiel stadt land fluss noch
mal richtig erklärt und zwar geht es bei
der app eigentlich nicht darum dass man
nebeneinander sitzt und an dem gleichen
handy
die stadt land fluss kategorien richtig
beantwortet mit dem buchstaben sondern
normalerweise spielen wir das ganze
spiel online hier gegen welche
zufälligen gegner oder gegen wegen
welche freunde von einem die irgendwo
anders sitzen noch nicht sagt allerdings
dass es vielleicht ein bisschen lustiger
ist wenn wir zusammen vor der kamera
sitzen deswegen habe es am gleichen
endgerät gespielt und deswegen haben
auch unterschiedliche buchstaben was
auch noch für das video ein bisschen
sinnvoller also deswegen ist es halt
nicht so dass wir zu beginn jeder runde
einzeln drehen weil normalerweise spielt
bereit einzelne spiele immer das heißt
jetzt noch nicht alles ein bisschen
kompliziert aber ich wollte euch nur
ganz kurz sagen was der grund dafür ist
dass anders als beispielsweise nicht
drehen musste allerdings in sandras
kategorien jetzt käsesorten ich verlor
meine berühmte marken berühmte
klassische musik und dinge die man nicht
berühren daher viel spart jetzt mit
sandras runter dann darfst deine zeit
meine damen und lang
oh mein gott jetzt direkt im ersten man
sieht ja gar nix durch diese brille
ich sehe was zu sagen
nicht nur der tanz eine komplett aus
sondern gleich auch danke übrigens auch
an google dass sie mir dafür das neue
google pixel zugesagt haben auf dem ihr
die sachen gerade zocken allerdings ich
möchte sagen ich mach' weiter mit meiner
runde in der nächsten runde sind meine
kategorien jetzt ein drache ist werben
werkzeuge tiere und deutsche tv
moderatorin mo zu denen eben manchmal
bekommt man einfach so direkten
buchstaben oder manchmal davon auch
selbst reden haben was aber relativ gut
ich habe buchstabe g ok de safe gysi ok
los geh jetzt mein drache ist richtig
geglaubt
glaubt man dran glaubt wir haben mit dr
essen werkzeuge mitgehen
werkzeuge mit
[Musik]
elektrorasierer danke für danke für den
tipp der gad ihre esel und deutsche tv
moderatorin
ich kenne keinen einzigen tv frank
elstner
oh mein gott alter sandra oh mein gott
ich fünf punkte habe mein alter ich
flippe im quadrat für elektror
alterskategorien für die nächste runde
sind wörter mit vier buchstaben werben
berühmte marken ein wort das ixs enthält
und bands und solokünstler
beziehungsweise künstlerin okay bei
sander geht wieder direkt obere auch mit
dem auch die stabe gm kategorien mit
vier oder mit vier buchstaben mit babys
sind da helfe ich dir werben
er soll die gleichen sachen die ich es
dort sehr gutes bis sehr gutes hat die
xxx xxx
die ex-freundin kann es machen und so
nur kunst damit mein gott wenn du fünf
punkten um mich besiegt hat jetzt obwohl
ich vier hatte
[Musik]
ich zieh dich ab des grau sind ich hatte
vier punkte und dachte ich wer krank mit
dabei du hast fünf ich hab doch gesagt
ja ich bin die schloss aus ganz
deutschland ich bin der tornado durch
ganz deutschland durch den bund an
deinen kopf letzte runde meine damen und
herren ich bekomme hier wieder
kategorien zugelost ich glaube das ist
einfach weil es bei uns abwechseln ist
einfach dass ich das zugelost bekommen
und den buchstaben direkt bekommt aber
bisher hast du immer glück was habe ich
vvl fasst eva bands und solokünstler mit
frau muss ich jetzt auch machen fällt
absolut nichts ein
kleidungsstücke mit v nehme ich einfach
[Musik]
es gibt nichts mit v oder werkzeuge mit
v was ist was so vogel
ich hab mir auch geholfen ein bisschen
musik genres mit v berühmte marken
volvo volvo ich hätte wohl angenommen
obwohl die machen bad armaturen und so
weiter und ist technisch sind ich hab
einen punkt volvo wenig dran und dazu
beginn meiner vorigen runde meine fünf
kategorien ausgelost und angezeigt
wurden habe ich da jetzt nicht noch mal
so einen spieler hier aufgenommen
allerdings hierfür sandra nochmal ihre
kategorien jetzt in dieser runde
kleidungsstücke körperteile bands und
solokünstler weise künstlerin starts
hauptstädte und länder also viel spaß
jetzt bei sandras letzten runde ein
buchstabe sondern einem stück mit wem
ein körperteil mit w
oh gott ich bin heftig bremst mit solo
künstler walter geb ich weiß was du bist
of watching bekomme ich dachte sagt wien
und ist doch auch richter ja was denn da
muss jeder sie mitgeschrieben washington
gibt ihnen das nachbarländer
weißrussland weiß weiß rosa und da haben
wir das ändern hinter das ende hinter
wien
nein nein nein zurück ok jetzt quasi
zusammen gemacht hier anhalt sei einfach
ein halber punkt bei weiter
level sind auch drei junge ja meine
damen und herren sondern erst mal mein
mann ist brille zurück ihr dankeschön
das war das heutige mobile man jetzt mit
luca video ich habe mir gedacht das
passt natürlich super wenn wir statt am
schluss spielen dass ihr das zusammen
mit meiner lieblings ja mein lieblings
menschen auf der welt jedoch nicht das
heutige video gefallen hat dann das und
einen daumen hoch unter dem video jedem
dank noch mal an der stelle an google
play das im rahmen der neuen kampagne
das video heute unterstützen
wann hat auf jeden fall die heutige
challenge gewonnen ihr seht gerade auch
schon über sandras gewicht das heutige
auto eingeblendet dass ich mich ein icon
von dem spiel stand schuster könnte
einfach draufklicken euch dass wir das
spiel runterladen könnt ihr selbst mal
zocken sagen wie weit ihr so kommt mit
dem buchstaben jetzt auch ein anderes
video verlinkt das ist nämlich das
letzte video von mobile man es mit luca
und schlag in die kommentare wer gewinnt
wer gewinnt ich etwas gefunden aber ich
bin doch auch da kann ich das schreiben
der gewinnt ja schreiben kommentare wer
bei euch gewinnt